a top Trump advisor enmeshment
allegations of wife-beating
the Republicans decide to blow out the
budget as always End Democratic women
decide that they have to get naked to
fight the patriarchy or something I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
oh we have so many great stories to get
to apparently coin tosses our racist I
will hope to get to that a little bit
later in the program as well there's
also a woman who's suggesting that women
only read books by women so I guess that
they should all read Fifty Shades of
Grey and not Tolstoy because the
patriarchy or somesuch but before we get
to any of those fun things first I want
to do something else fun and that is say
thank you to our sponsors over at man
crates so man crates calm it's the only
way to get the best gift for the man in
your life and we're talking about
curated gift collections for every type
of guy from sports fanatic to the home
chef to the outdoorsman you can check
out classics like the NFL bar work wait
the crate the whiskey appreciation
crates or fresh takes on traditional
Valentine's Day gifts like your guy he
doesn't want a box of chocolates he
wants a jerky heart yeah or he wants a
salami bouquet your incredible go-to man
creates a calm you pick the perfect gift
and then wait for that magic moment for
it to arrive when it arrives very often
the gifts they come in various different
types there's one that I got that
actually comes in an ammo box but they
also have a wooden crate this is what
they are famous for their wooden crates
and they come with a with an actual
crowbar and then it is up to the man to
pry open it and we will see if he's not
man enough then you should divorce him
or leave him but if he's a real man he
can pry open that man crate with either
his bare hands as I did or he can do it
with the National crowbar it is a great
thrill and when you look inside the gift
is just as great as the creative
thousands of five-star reviews every
gift comes with a complete satisfaction
guarantee so go-to man crates calm slash
Ben for 5% off again that's man crates
calm slash Ben for 5% off right now as I
said my most recent gift from man crates
wasn't engraved guitar which I've been
using to seduce my wife I don't even
play it I just stand under the window
and then I just stand there looking all
broody and it was working great so far
so men crates calm slash Ben and you get
five percent off who's that / Ben as
well so we know he's saying I love that
ad read so much okay so let's get into
something that is not good so now we
have to get serious because there's
actually a terrible terrible story so it
turns out that one of trumps top aides
getting robbed Porter nobody's ever
heard of Rob Porter he's just one of
these guys who hangs around the
president I know some folks in the White
House they say that Rob Porter was
indeed very close
the president obviously that is true
he's in half of the pictures with the
president and apparently Rob Porter is
not good to his ladies so in his first
ex-wife he has I guess two ex-wives is
the idea that I don't know what it is
about Trump and the people who surround
him or who are his fans but there are
there are a lot of thrice-married people
or at least twice married people twice
divorced people who surround president
Trump in any case this one is actually
not on Trump Rob Porter was in aid to to
General John Kelly I seen as sort of his
right hand helping to ensure that the
wrong people don't get into the Oval
Office to talk to the President of the
United States
well apparently his first ex-wife is is
accused Rob Porter of spousal abuse and
there is a picture of this apparently
his first his first ex-wife is her name
is Kobe Holderness and she spoke on the
record to Daily Mail climb about their
five-year marriage apparently they met
at their Mormon Church in 2000 while
they were in college she says that he
was never physically abusive until her
honeymoon and that floored me and then
she said quote he would throw me down on
the bed put his full body weight on top
of me then grind a knee or elbow into my
body expressing rage she says the
violence escalated to the point reporter
was choking her quote it was not hard
enough for me to pass out but it was
scary humiliating and dehumanizing
and here is a picture that she posted of
herself apparently he took the picture
he says I took the picture says right i
guilted him into taking the picture so
that is a shiner right there that is
that is not good stuff just horrifying
and then there is Jennifer Willoughby
Jennifer will be as Porter's second to
ex-wife who shared the story of her
abusive marriage with Daily Mail calm
I believe we actually have video of her
talking about her abusive marriage to
rob Porter this top trump aid I did know
that my marriage was was bad I knew that
it wasn't healthy that we that the
fights and the verbal and emotional
abuse that I was enduring was not quote
unquote normal but I don't think that I
had yet put myself in the category of
someone whose husband laid hands on her
until that moment Rob and I were married
in November of 2009 it was a very quick
courtship and engagement within a matter
a couple of weeks after being married I
was aware of his temper okay and his
temper apparently escalated all the way
up to apparently dragging her wedding
naked out of the shower and verbally
abusing her calling her an effing B the
White House originally gave Porter its
full support by the way I believe
there's an ex-girlfriend now who's come
out and also accused him of this sort of
activity which is just wonderful the
White House originally came out and
defended Rob Porter they said that they
didn't see anything you know they didn't
see anything that was worthy of firing
him over and then the picture came out
of the black eye and suddenly they have
shifted their tune so Porter said in his
original statement quote these
outrageous allegations are simply false
I took the photos given to the media
nearly 15 years ago and the reality
behind them is nowhere close to what is
being described I'd like to hear what
she hit in the face by a door did she do
that with makeup like what happened I've
been transparent and truthful about
these vile claims but I will not further
engage publicly with a coordinated smear
campaign my commitments public service
speaks for itself I've always put duty
to country first and treated others with
respect I'm deeply grateful for the
opportunity to have served in the Trump
administration and will seek to ensure a
smooth transition when I leave the White
House apparently originally the the
answer from John Kelly was that he came
to the defense right originally John
Kelly statement was that that he stood
by Porter the DEM trying to find the
edge of the actual text so let's see
apparently he he originated Ellie's
original statement stated quote that he
that Rob Porter is a man of true
integrity and honor and I can't say
enough good things about him he is a
friend to confront an entrusted
professional I'm proud to serve
alongside him that's the quote that was
circulating online as of last night
before cold the Colby Horrell Holderness
his black eye came out then of course
they shifted tune and and they decided
that things had changed the question is
what did they know and when did they
know it over at the White House did they
know all along this guy was an accused
spousal abuser he didn't have his FBI
clearance apparently because of all of
these allegations apparently the first
ex-wife called up the White House
Counsel time again that's what CNN was
reporting and actually told Don McGann
about this it was never relayed to the
President of the United States
CNN reported last night quote senior
aides to President Donald Trump
months about allegations of domestic
abuse levied against top White House
staffer Rob Porter by his ex-wives even
as Porter's stock in the West Wing
continued to rise multiple sources told
CNN on Wednesday
Porter denied the allegations but
resigned on Wednesday a scramble ensued
inside the West Wing to defend him when
the claims became public this week that
effort continued even after his
resignation according to sources this is
CNN sources he have to take all that
with a grain of salt obviously they're
not named says senior White House
officials were aware for months of the
allegations made against Trump's staff
secretary according to two sources Trump
himself first learned of the allegations
this week so it really wasn't Trump he
was upset when Sean reports of the abuse
his daughter Ivanka was also deeply
disturbed by the allegations
particularly the photographs so
apparently by early follows widely known
among cops Trump aides including chief
of staff John Kelly both the porter was
facing troubles in obtaining FBI
clearance and that his ex-wives claimed
he had abused them so that's a pretty
significant allegation that months ago
Kelly knew what was going on here and he
didn't do anything instead Kelly and
others oversaw an elevation in Porter's
saying that's a fireable offense okay if
John Kelly knew that the that this is
the guy who's getting closer and closer
to the President of the United States
was in fact an alleged spousal abuser
who could not obtain FBI clearance right
if that's the case then there's no not
only is there no excuse for it but but
Kelly needs to go right if Kelly knew
that there was a guy who had three
separate allegations of abuse against
him and a restraining order taken out
against him and and also in a temper I
think that the police had slapped some
sort of some sort of legal bar on him in
any case if if Kelly knew all of that he
let him get close to Trump that's a
dereliction of duty to protect his boss
as ila pond it says Kelly in the White
House Counsel Tom McGann left Trump
vulnerable by refusing to disarm the
grenade The Times of London suggests a
yeah the New York Times sorry claims
that Kelly was duped by Porter but that
excuse really doesn't only go so far it
says to White House officials who asked
not to be identified because they were
not authorized to speak about the
internal deliberations insisted that mr.
Porter had misled mr. Kelly and several
other aides about the severity of the
allegations he had portrayed the woman
is making up stories to cause trouble
and few if any aides in the White House
considered conducting their own
investigations to discover what might
have taken place in fact it turns out
that Rob Porter was apparently dating
hope Hicks who's another top aide to the
president hope Hicks has terrible taste
in men apparently
also supposedly dated corey lewandowski
a married man on the campaign trail
corey lewandowski famous for grabbing
michelle fields and then lying about it
so she she has really top-notch taste in
mendes does hope hicks she may be a nice
gal but she really needs to examine her
choices in life better if all of this is
true about rob but about about rob
Porter so you know the rumor is that
Kelly is gonna pay for it I doubt that
Kelly is gonna pay for it more likely
that they just claimed that he didn't
know in the first place that all of this
was going on but you know Sarah Huckabee
Sanders essentially dodged the question
so Sarah Huckabee sandra's asked about
this and she says the porter made the
decision to leave look I think that was
a personal decision that Rob made and
one that he was not pressured to do but
one that he made on his own so the he is
out at the White House but I don't think
this blowback is going to end anytime
soon and there will be serious questions
asked about who knew what when and and
why and and there is gonna be an
allegation that's made about the White
House and the allegations made about the
White House's that they go easy on
people who are accused of abusing women
because if they don't go easy on those
people then it might reduce on Trump it
might bounce back on Trump there might
be people who say well you're so hard on
on Rob Porter weren't you harder on
President Trump there were allegations
made in his divorce proceedings by a
Vong by Ivana Trump that he actually
raped her that was in the divorce
proceeding way back in the 1980s so why
is it that that you know Trump is
treated by a different standard than he
treats his own aides that's where the
media is going to go next with this that
said there's no excuse for anybody
covering up this sort of stuff if they
knew about it and it's it's again their
election of duty if John Kelly knew
about it and did nothing because he was
friendly with Rob Porter so he has his
final statement here he says I stand by
my previous comments on the Rob Porter
that I've come to know since becoming
chief of staff I believe every
individual deserves the right to defend
their reputation I accepted his
resignation earlier today and will
ensure a swift and orderly transition he
says I was shocked by the new
allegations released against rapport
there's no place for domestic violence
in our society but I'm wondering exactly
how that squares with the I believe Rob
Porter on virtually everything okay so
in just a second I'm going to get into
the the conservatives who are who are
lining up behind a bad budget deal first
I want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at filter by comm so it's that time
of year it's cold outside I mean you're
spending an awful lot of time in
house there's only one problem the air
in your house is significantly dirtier
by studies than the air outside your
house which is why you need to make sure
that the filters that you use in your
furnace system and your air conditioning
that those filters are actually not
dirty and spewing a bunch of garbage
into the air that you are breathing
that's what filter by comm is for there
America's leading provider of HVAC
filters for homes and small businesses
they carry over 600 different filter
sizes including custom options all
shipped free within 24 hours plus
they're manufactured right here in
America in Ellison I know talking about
air filters is not the sexiest thing but
it's also the thing that's gonna keep
you alive longer al-kidd fact is the
dirty air makes you more unhealthy it's
the thing that's going to improve your
quality of life so go over to filter by
comm they offer a multitude of ME RV
options all the way up to hospital grade
so you'll be removing dangerous pollen
mold dust other allergy aggravating
pollution while maximizing the
efficiency of your system right now save
five percent when you set up auto
delivery so you never need to think
about those air filters again again
that's filter by comm filter bu why.com
filter by comm and you save five percent
when you set up that auto delivery so
you never need to think about air
filters again they just show up and when
they show up you replace them and then
everything is all cool ok so meanwhile
while all of this is going down in the
Whitehouse Chuck Schumer and Mitch
McConnell have come up with a budget
deal yay
except whenever there's a bipartisan
Budget deal the bipartisan Budget deal
sucks ok there's no such thing as a good
bipartisan budget deal they're all
garbage whenever there's bipartisan
budget deal means they're gonna blow out
the budget because the truth is then
what really drives our national debt
international deficit are the
entitlements it is not military spending
it is not the ancillary spending it is
not foreign aid right there's a lot of
waste and fraud and abuse in the budget
but when Trump said that he was going to
cut the government down to size by
whittling away at that
that's nonsense the only way that you're
actually going to cut the government
down to size is to do something that no
one wants to do now look it is
politically it is politically
unpalatable to talk seriously about what
needs to happen with the American budget
the American budget breaks down heavily
on the side of entitlement programs
right entitlement programs that
generates an enormous amount of the
American budget every single year
military spending only accounts for the
the military spending only accounts for
approximately 20% of the American of the
American budget so the vast majority of
the American budget every year is taken
up instead by the
by the entitlement programs that all of
these people supposedly supposedly rely
upon
now there's discretionary spending right
discretionary spending a lot of that is
defense in homeland security so by 2015
standards for example the discretionary
spending for defense and homeland
security was 54 percent of discretionary
spending but that's not where the vast
majority of the budget goes if you look
at the share of all spending which is
what we actually need to do right that's
what we actually need to look at 16% of
all spending is military spending by
2015 standards that'll probably rise to
closer to 20% this year the Health and
Human Services Department which means
Medicare right that is 28% of all
discretion or a discretionary mandatory
spending 25% of all discretionary and
mandatory spending is Social Security
that means that nearly 60% right that's
53% of all spending in the budget is
just from Medicare and Social Security
and that doesn't count welfare programs
food and agriculture which is really the
food stamp program that's 4% of the
budget on the education is that our
three percent of the budget State
Department foreign aid is two percent of
the budget but the two biggest numbers
on that list are not military they are
Medicare and Medicaid and Social
Security that's where all the money is
going and nobody wants to touch that
stuff Paul Ryan wants to touch that
stuff Trump does not want to touch that
stuff Mitch McConnell doesn't want to
touch that stuff Republicans in Congress
don't want to touch that stuff they are
afraid there will be blowback so instead
they've come up with just another budget
compromise that really amounts to we
agree to spend a crapload of money do
you agree to spend a crapload of money
sure let's all agree to spend a crapload
of money now you're not hearing a lot
from the Tea Partiers now it just goes
to show you the Tea Party has basically
been sold sucked I think by the Trump
movement and that's that's a serious
problem
all right President Trump has been good
for a lot of things he's not good on
this he's not good on entitlement she
was never good on entitlements during
the campaign he said he didn't want to
change Social Security in fact he wanted
to increase the amounts in Social
Security and increase the amounts
available through Medicare so the idea
that Trump was ever going to be a Tea
Party ally in the sense that the Tea
Party was about curbing government
spending was not true and the problem is
that if the Tea Party does not spend and
stand up to bad government spending on
both sides they're going to be accused
of simply being anti Obama as opposed to
being principled so they really should
be standing up to this budget deal which
is a garbage budget deal okay the deal
would add five hundred billion dollars
in federal
for both defense and non-defense
spending why do you have to come up with
a compromise budget deal in the first
place you got 51 Republicans in the
Senate you got a big majority in the
house why do you have to come up with a
compromise budget deal the answer is you
don't force the Democrats to filibuster
a budget deal that gets rid of defense
sequestration but keeps caps on
discretionary spending in other aspects
of the budget force them to do that
they're not gonna get away with that
they try to shut down the government two
weeks ago and it failed but instead
Republicans didn't have the stones for
that and the Senate at least so
conservative lawmakers and organizations
are of course saying this is fiscally
irresponsible because it is fiscally
irresponsible Paul Ryan is saying they
have the votes for it he just wants the
Democrats to go along with it
representative mo Brooks who's a
conservative from Alabama he says the
spending bill is a debt junkies dream
I'm not only you know I'm a hell mo Club
for Growth is urging members of Congress
to vote no on the big government budget
and they say in 2011 when Congress
passed the Budget Control Act Senate
Leader Mitch McConnell praised the deal
proclaiming the big government freight
train was slowing down
well now the BCA spending caps are
busted under the seal again and it's
clear that McConnell and the GOP wants
to speed up the big government freight
train with the help of big spending
liberals on the other side of the aisle
apparently the deal includes eighty
billion plus in so-called disaster
relief spending erroneous tax extenders
an expansion of farm subsidies another
suspension in the debt ceiling
conveniently timed to expire after the
midterm elections
nowhere in the deal are the 54 billion
dollars in spending cuts outlined in
Trump's budget instead the big
government freight train is running out
of control so this is a continuing blot
nonetheless President Trump of course is
pleased with the deal because Trump just
wants to deal look Trump is not a
principled guy when it comes to budgets
we know that and he signed a budget over
the objections of his own Republican
Party back in what was in November when
he called Schumer and Pelosi into his
office negotiated a deal with them on
his own which amounted to do whatever
you want with the budget Trump just
doesn't want the government to shut down
again because he doesn't want the blame
for it the media blowback he tweeted out
yesterday quote the budget agreement
today is so important for our great
military it ends the dangerous sequester
and gives secretary mattis what he needs
to keep America great Republicans and
Democrats must support our troops and
support this bill so this is the game
Republicans play the game is will raise
military spending and when we raise
military spending a few other things go
up that's okay because we need more
military spending the game Democrats
play is they say well I guess we'll be
ok with the military spending if you
allow us to blow out the budget on these
other element
bottom line is America spends way too
much money the deficits are not
occurring because we're not taking in
enough tax revenue they're occurring
because we're spending out the wazoo and
this new budget deal which breaks the
sequestration is not a good thing
there's a reason that the National
Review editorial board came out today
and condemned the deal they were
obviously you know more concerned with
the with the spending that's
non-military but I think there's some
good arguments that military spending
you know that it's always easy to say we
need more spending on the military but
instead that military spending should
actually be more targeted the national
view editorial board writes today that
the deal would raise budget caps that
were established by the Budget Control
Act in 2011 familes 300 billion just
over the next two years it would also
fund the government for the next months
while the Appropriations Committee
decides where to direct the money this
is a bad deal it's bad because it hikes
domestic spending it also ends the canoe
chance for a conservative legislative
achievement in 2018 how so - you're
spending deal means Republicans probably
won't go to the trouble of passing a
formal budget for 2019
that means no chance for a so-called
reconciliation process that could allow
them to enact meaningful legislation
with only 50 votes in the Senate this is
a great point once the government is
funded then you can't use the
reconciliation process right you can
only use the reconciliation process if
there's a formal budget because the way
the reconciliation process works is that
if you can so here's the way that you
pass a bill you need normally 51 votes
to pass a bill Democrats can filibuster
that takes your limit up to 60 you need
now 60 votes to pass a bill in order for
you to pass a bill with 51 votes under
reconciliation you have to show that
your budget that your new bill would be
budget neutral that would not add to the
debt if there is no budget there is no
line against which to gauge if a bill is
budget neutral or not which means that
you can't use reconciliation so national
view says if Republicans accept this
deal and then forego the reconciliation
process that will given up their chance
to pass a while without Democratic
support and measures such as easing the
Obamacare regulations that will
contribute to higher premiums in the
coming years or reforming welfare will
stand no chance of making it through
Congress with the steal Republicans are
hurting the chance to add to their
ledger of accomplishments prior to
November which of course is true the
actual cost of this bill will be a 1.5 a
trillion dollars over the next decade
which is just as expensive as tax reform
so again bad deal by Republicans but
this is not rare I mean they're always
making these sorts of deals because
there
attempting to avoid political blame and
the easiest way to avoid political blame
in our politics is not to be fiscally
conservative fiscal conservatives
unfortunately are unicorns they exist
only in our imagination this is true by
polls if you look at Americans they are
fiscally conservative they always say we
wish the government would spend less and
then you ask them would you like to cut
this program and the answer is no would
you like to cut that program and the
answer is no a lot of that is because
the growth of the federal government has
enshrined in our minds that we need the
federal government in order to protect
us from the vicissitudes of life
unfortunately but you know the truth is
that's not true this is why you have
States is why you have localities this
is why you have communities the federal
government is not there to fill every
gap but we as a country have decided
that the federal government is there to
fill these gaps and therefore if the
federal government were to shut down or
if we were to cut these programs
millions would die millions would die
now what's hysterical about all of this
is that Trump doesn't have to do this in
order to win right Trump right now is
actually winning the polls show that
trumps approval is all the way back up
to about Barack Obama's approval at the
time at this time in his presidency so
according to the Rasmussen Daly
presidential tracking poll 48 percent of
likely u.s. voters approve of Trump's
job performance there's another poll I
saw yesterday daily tracking poll that
had Trump up to 45% in the daily
tracking poll the Democrats remain
unpopular on issues that Trump remains
popular so it's not like Trump had to be
forced into this right sound like Trump
was was on the verge of collapsing if he
didn't do what he was supposed to do
here but instead he's decided to back a
budget program because he doesn't want
the blowback he's basically gonna gamble
that everything the Republicans have
done is enough to get them over the
finish line in 2018 and will be enough
to get them over the finish line in 2020
I'm not sure that that's the case the
only thing that stands for that the
other things standing in favor of that
proposition is that the Democrats
continue to be absolutely awful with
their jobs and in just a second I'm
gonna show you just how terrible the
Democrats are at their jobs because the
Republicans are about to pass a bad
budget and Democrats don't know what to
do because they're terrible absolutely
terrible at this first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at
movement watches so you've heard me talk
about movement you know that there are
these two college dropouts who started
their own watch company and this company
has now sold 2 million watches in over
160 countries and that's because their
watches are amazing look at this one
this is my
this is one of my to movement watches my
wife also has a movement watch I got one
for my mom for her birthday as well
Moomin watches are just terrific and
Valentine's Day is just around the
corner you wanted a great Valentine's
Day gift surprise your loved ones
there's a matter man woman they have
great men's watches they're great
women's watches as well and movement
watches are minimalist in design and
they are not expensive they last they
are just terrific as I've said I have a
one and a half year old son he loves my
movement watched so much that he steals
it from me and twice we have found it in
his car seat after he's bashful living
crap out of it it is doing fine right it
looks just as good as the day that I
bought it it is just terrific so check
it out movement watches for Valentine's
Day and they're offering right now
custom Valentine's Day boxes featuring a
watch and bracelet and just like their
watches the beautiful bracelets come in
a variety of finishes and styles the
bracelets are a perfect complement both
to the watch to the movement watcher and
they are beautiful to wear on their own
and they can be stacked with the watches
as well
well they again those fashion-forward
bracelets their designs like classic
cuffs and trendy barbed-wire finishes
gold rose gold matte black you name it
they start at just $40 now you get 15%
off today with free shipping and free
returns by going to movement right MVM
t-dot-com slash Shapiro that's MVM t.com
slash Shapiro check it out mb mt comm
slash Shapiro you get 15% off today a
lot of my fans have gotten em VMT
watches they're happy with them I am
happy with my MVM T watch because it's
great-looking and again they have the
bracelets as well now so they're
offering custom Valentine's Day boxes
featuring both and watch and a bracelet
makes a great gift MVM t-dot-com
slash a Pierrot joined the movement use
that / apparel so they know that we sent
you okay so well the Republicans passed
a giant budget because fiscal
conservatism does not exist anymore and
Republicans should be resisting this
budget not going along to get along for
president Trump's sake the Democrats
continue to stink at this and yesterday
Nancy Pelosi decided that it would be
worthwhile to stand up there for eight
hours and jabber nonsensically about why
we can't pass a budget because we need
to protect illegal immigrants so her
complaint what she should have said hey
she doesn't listen we made a budget
sequestration deal it rained in spending
for the first time in forever
she should have stood up for the deal
that she helped cut back in 2011 she
should have said listen we made a deal
then the deals still good you want to
lower we were spending too much money we
just spent a lot of money on a tax cuts
you should have talked fiscal
responsibility instead because demo
nuts and because Democrats have decided
they want to Bank on identity politics
overall Nancy Pelosi gets up there and
she jabbers about daca and deferred
action for childhood arrivals and about
shutting down the government on behalf
of illegal immigrants ID States of
America well know that these dreamers
are part of that history and that their
stories will be there to make judgments
about us as to how we have responded to
their greatness she went on and on and
on and on and on I mean just hey there
is there any video of this woman I'm not
sure who was who's sitting behind her
during this who started falling asleep
during the speech and every time Pelosi
would turn in her vague direction should
sort of wake herself up it's really
really funny first of all the media
treated this as those great heroism so
when when Ted Cruz did this it was the
end of the world over Obamacare when Ted
Cruz said listen I'd rather not fund
Obamacare and have a government shutdown
then fund Obamacare and not have a
government shutdown the media went nuts
and when Ted gave his filibuster
everybody oh my god how could ted cruz
do this look at this grandstanding Nancy
Pelosi stands there for eight hours and
all the headlines are look at courageous
Nancy Pelosi look at that just
incredible just incredible the bravery
of Nance play mean it's like Normandy I
saw a tweet yesterday somebody from the
media saying she's been standing there
for five hours five hours without
drinking or going to the bathroom yeah
so like so on it's like I do that like
pretty much every day like way I mean
sure she's a thousand years old so I
guess from a physical level that's
pretty amazing but yeah the kind of
worship for Nancy Pelosi for doing this
is really stupid also Republicans
apparently a lot of Democrats were
pissed a lot of Democrats were saying
why is Nancy Pelosi grandstanding like
this we're trying to kind of deal with
Trump to get past this we don't want to
be seen as shutting down the government
for illegal immigrants again the Nancy
Pelosi can't help herself the best the
best quote from her speech yesterday is
where she explained that she has a
grandson who apparently wants to be a
black person I don't know why that's
worthy of note on the floor of the house
but sure all right this was such a proud
day for me because when my grandson blew
out the candles on his cake they said
did you make a wish and he said yes I
made a wish
so what is your wish she said I wish I
had brown skin and brown eyes like I'm
Tony oh so beautiful so beautiful the
beauty is in the mix why now I'm just
like this is your this is your pitch
your pictures we should shut down the
government because my grandson wants to
be black first of all they did this
whole this whole line of thought from
Democrats that you want to be a black
person therefore that means that you're
a better person like I just don't
understand that it just because the
converse obviously doesn't hold true
right in Brown versus Board of Education
one of the one of the logic one of the
points of logic used by the court in
defense of the idea that segregation
should be illegal is that too many black
kids wanted to be white so apparently if
you want to be black that's great if you
want to be white that's terrible how
about this how about we all just don't
care about our skin color like if you're
black you wouldn't care and if you're
white you wouldn't care and if you're a
green you wouldn't care because who
cares I mean honest to god who cares
what a stupid thing it's so stupid but
again this is the entire Democratic
Party they have an opening here to push
fiscal responsibility right they can
actually grab away the the idea of
fiscal responsibility from Republicans
instead they're gonna go full-out
density politics it's not just Nancy
Pelosi they continue to associate with
kook's like Linda Sarsour Linda Sarsour
of course who has supported terrorists
in the past Linda Sarsour who is an
anti-semite extreme Linda Sarsour who is
just a disgusting human being she is she
was featured in this speech by again one
of these women's marches and she ripped
into Chuck Schumer because Chuck Schumer
actually wants to kind of deal with
Trump because he's politically smarter
than Nancy Pelosi and SAR Souter says
that she is tired of white men
negotiating on the backs of people of
color
okay one of the things that's hilarious
about Linda Sarsour saying that of
course the Linda Sarsour once said that
until she had actually converted to
Islam that she was considered white so
very weird that she has a changed her
definition based on that but again if
this is how Kratz want to go go for it
man
go for it right Trump Trump will
continue to win Republicans will
continue to win if you keep banking on
this sort of idiotic politics even some
members of the Democratic Party
understand this representative Tim Ryan
who if the Democrats were smart they'd
make him Speaker of the House he's
representative from Ohio and he says
listen our economic messaging is just
terrible
right our economic messaging sucks we're
focusing on all the wrong stuff we're
focusing on identity politics it's why
we're gonna lose I'm wondering if you
think some of your colleagues regret
keeping Pelosi around in that position
of power considering power considering
some of the things she's recently said
well I mean you're gonna have to talk to
them about it I will just say that I
don't think that the Democratic Party as
a whole both in the house and in the
Senate have sharpened a economic message
that speaks to the aspirations of most
Americans yeah you think you think I
mean obviously that's the case and
Democrats should be very very concerned
about that when one of the reasons that
they should be concerned is because all
there's so many Democrats who really are
out of touch thinking about a touch Katy
tur over at MSNBC right she actually was
talking about how Trump had suggested
that there were a thousand dollar tax
cuts for a lot of people and then she
basically she doubled down on suggesting
that $1,000 is nothing right and
thousand dollars is nothing if you're
making half a million dollars you're
like Katy tur but if you're making
$40,000 a year and you get a thousand
dollar tax break you're making sixty
grand a year you get a thousand dollar
tax break that's not no money I mean
that pays for your car insurance for
half a year for some folks right here's
Katy tour the doubling down on it Alison
ever and $1,000 is a very big deal but
along with cheering one time bonuses
shouldn't we be pushing for long term
salary hikes the kind of sustained help
that would transform big-ticket dreams
into everyday realities because think
about it starting a family owning a home
sending your kids to college these
should be within the reach of every
American bonus or no bonus or does that
make me seem
touch I'm just not sure just just yes it
does make you seem out of touch it makes
you seem out of touch when you suggest
that $1,000 is not a lot of money and
then you say well I was just pushing for
more well it wasn't just that you were
pushing for more because if you were
pushing from where you want lower taxes
wouldn't you but she's not interested in
lower taxes because she's a Democrat
again this sort of out of touch feeling
from the Democrats is what is going to
doom them if they continue by the way
the reader the districting in 2018 is
really bad for Democrats there's a study
out from 538 that shows that even if
Democrats were to win on the generic
ballot by 7 points they might not pick
up any serious ground in the house they
could they could win a few more seats
there there was a shift in a bunch of
seats from lean R to lean D but that may
not be enough for Democrats to pick up
seats in the house and take the majority
so pretty pretty amazing that they could
go through this entire political cycle
and still not end up with the Senate or
the house just amazing well when we
continue here I want to discuss Sports
Illustrated Swimsuit Edition is doing
something incredible something
incredible to stand up for women and and
stands up to the patriarchy it's
something that's when I say incredible I
mean unbelievably stupid I'll get to
that in just a second but for that
you're gonna have to subscribe for $9.99
a month you get the rest of this show
live you get the rest of the Michael
Noel's show live you get the rest of the
Andrew Clavin show live and if you need
to date this Valentine's Day this
Wednesday February 14th at 5 p.m.
Eastern the lonely and desperate Michael
moles will literally be waiting for your
questions in our next episode of the
conversation his hopeless pleas for
attention will stream live on Facebook
YouTube in The Daily wire website it's
free for everybody to watch only
subscribers can join the website and ask
the questions to ask questions as a
subscriber you log into our website at
Daley we're calm and you head over to
the conversation page to watch the live
stream after that you start typing into
the daily wired chat box where Michael
will answer live questions as they come
in for an entire hour by sitting there
and staring blankly into a camera once
again subscribe to get your questions
answered by Michael moles this
Valentine's Day on Wednesday February
14th at 5 p.m. Eastern 2 p.m. Pacific
and join the conversation my first
question when I log in will be why do
you still work here but unfortunately I
cannot actually that's my fault I could
do something about it but thus far I've
just been too lazy or stupid to do so in
any case if you want the annual
subscription you get all of those after
mentioned glories as well as the leftist
tears hot or cold tumblr it is so
fantastic
make your life better in every
conceivable way all the ways will make
you richer it will make you more
handsome it will make you it will make
you more happy and if none of those
things come true then at least you'll
still have a mug in your in your
cupboard so just spectacular okay if you
want to listen later go to iTunes
SoundCloud YouTube please subscribe to
our YouTube channel it's the daily wire
YouTube channel so check that out we are
the largest fastest growing podcast as a
conservative podcast in the nation
okay so now I'm about to do a little bit
mansplaining it's time for some
mansplaining so in order for me man's
plane here the reason when a man's plane
is because I'm about to mansplain men to
women okay and this I think I am
qualified to do as a man so I'm not
gonna man's plane to women how women
should think about themselves with their
lives or their bodies that's that that's
your business I don't really care do
what you want to do but I will man's
plane to you what it's like to be a man
because I know and you don't because I'm
a man right you can't woman explained to
me what it's like to be a man just like
I can't man's plane to you what it's
like to be one so here is some
mansplaining and as Andrew Clavin says
let's try to do some women understanding
so here is a problem okay the Sports
Illustrated Swimsuit Issue is made for
men to get off ok let's be real about
this the vast majority of men who
subscribed in Sports Illustrated are men
vast majority of people who subscribe to
Sports Illustrated are men and those men
tend to like beautiful women which is
why half of the ads and Sports
Illustrated are scantily clad women hold
in sports drinks there's a reason for
that it's not because men are deeply
concerned with the with the inner beauty
of a woman right that's just not the
case there's no there's a line in liar
liar where where Jim Carrey who's the
the whole premise of the film is that he
can no longer lie because he's received
a curse from his son and his son comes
out of class and Jim Carrey is talking
about how at one point his wife was was
pregnant and fat and the son says
something like my teacher says true
beauty's on the inside and Jim Carrey
says that's just something ugly people
say ok the reason that that's a laugh
line is because that's how a lot of men
think ok that's that's men's instinct
men's instinct is to look at a woman's
physical beauty which is why all
actresses you know all of these
celebrities who talk so much about the
patriarchy are beautiful right they're
all good-looking ok then the vast
majority of actresses in Hollywood are
not they don't look like Melissa
McCarthy they look like Jessica Chastain
they're all gorgeous women
okay so Sports Illustrated Swimsuit
Edition decides that it's time to have
their own mating moments and the way
they're gonna have their me to moment is
by demonstrating that the patriarchy can
be smashed with naked beautiful women so
Vanity Fair writes about this hey on the
shortlist of American media institutions
invented to take commercial advantage of
the male gaze first of all I hate this
in this phrase the male gaze it's called
instinct okay men look at beautiful
women just like women look at attractive
men although not exactly
that because the fact is that a woman is
more likely to to get to know a man and
make a judgement based on that than a
man is likely to get to know a woman
outside of the physical okay the reality
is men are much more driven by sex than
women this is true in virtually every
every species and men are the ones who
initiate sex males are the ones who
initiate sex in virtually every species
they're the ones who seek sex more
aggressively and we're often in
virtually every species sorry to break
break two folks but this is just biology
the male gaze Sports Illustrated
Swimsuit Edition
surely ranks in the top three mostly
safe for work Division one could be
forgiven them for thinking that the
staff of the issue were reconsidering
their efforts last fall as Michu trended
stories about sexual harassment consumed
news cycles and audiences thought more
deeply about the ways their media and
entertainment were made and who was
making them it turns out the issues
staff had already been on their way to
rethinking all of it according to Vanity
Fair at her MJ day and her core team
comprised of all women had decided as
early as last spring to try in 2018 to
make a magazine where models were as
much participants as objects she says
quote I'm thrilled this movement is
going on because I feel like it's gonna
change things for the better
apparently she runs the swimsuit issue
like a den mother paying attention to
the emotions and comfort level of models
and employees just this is a safe space
she loves to post selfies with the model
she works with and last year uploaded a
photograph of herself in a bikini in the
name of body positivity yes I'm sure
that men are thinking about the
positivity I mean it is amazing how men
and women can see the same image and see
two different things I guarantee you
that if you show a woman this picture
the first thing that most women will see
is the word artist on this lady's arm if
you show a man this picture that is
about the seventh thing the man will see
okay no joke okay mathis can confirm
this
okay the reality is that if you're a man
and you look at this picture it takes
you a long time to realize there are
actual words on this woman's body
because she's naked okay and men are
into naked women sorry to break it to
women this is the way that it works for
day the 2018 issue which arrives on
newsstands next week will be the
culmination of a shift in her thinking
that's happened over her time at Sports
Illustrated that the images could be a
place where different standards of
beauty could be celebrated traveling and
shooting on location put her in
situations where she was talking about
bodies and the idea of beauty with
people from vastly different cultural
milieus okay so I'll be curious to see
if the swimsuit issue features a bunch
very very overweight women let's let's
show some more of these of these images
that smash the patriarchy so here is a
very sexy woman wearing a bikini that
she seems to be pulling down and a
skimpy shirt that is wet demonstrating
that she does indeed have nipples
beneath the shirt right and then it says
something on the butt I couldn't read
what was on the shirt because I was
distracted by all the other things okay
cuz I'm a man because that's how men
works as a woman does not have to be
immodest in order to be respected okay a
woman does have to be modest in order
for a man to read what's on her t-shirt
okay I agree you don't have to I respect
you as a woman right and I would check
your credentials if I were hiring but
I'm not looking at what's on your shirt
lady I'm looking at what's beneath the
shirt because that's the way men operate
okay that's not sexism
that's called human biology a woman does
not have to be modest in order to be
respected no but again a woman has to be
modest in order for me to pay attention
to what's coming out of the words coming
out of her face my goodness okay here's
another one he said these are all to
smash the patriarchy it here's a naked
another beautiful naked woman again I'm
not seeing a lot of ugly naked women in
this particular issue a beautiful naked
woman putting her hand over her breasts
and her other hand over her over her
lady parts and it says mother and then
it says beneath her hand something that
you can't read because her hand is
covering the word it says human I guess
so apparently Justin Trudeau will be
lecturing her about use of the word
human it should say person and then it
says nurturer on her arm and then
something down her leg the you can read
because she's naked okay again ladies
men's brains operate on two level just
like everyone's brains operate on two oh
there's the level of instinct and
there's the level of reason right
there's the prefrontal cortex which
allows you to do your higher-level
thinking and then there's your lizard
brain
okay men's lizard brain kicks in women
okay women who are married know this the
worst time to talk about matters of
great import is in the middle of a
sexual pic peccadillo okay this is not a
good time to talk about the taxes men
are not going to be paying attention
that's not their fault I mean not
everything that you dislike about the
world means that it's a man's fault it's
not a man's fault it a man who looks at
this picture is more likely thinking
what's under the hands then how do I
complete that crossword puzzle on her
chest okay do we have one more is this
the last one
I say here's the last one beautiful
naked woman smiling in what is obviously
a sexual pose completely naked right
lying back replete lying back you know
vulnerable and then it says on her rib
cage truth again I don't know what
that's supposed to mean
I don't know why truth on her rib cage
is supposed to is supposed to mean
anything there's an H on her butt which
I again don't know what the rest of the
word says because there's no way to tell
I don't mean talk about truth gonna talk
about reality here is the reality men
read Sports Illustrated men buy the
swimsuit edition now I'm the kind of man
who respects women so much than when I
was a teenager when I was teenager and
the first time I got Sports Illustrated
I called the number I unsubscribe from
the swimsuit edition which you can do it
right can unsubscribe from the swimsuit
issue so for years and years and years I
got Sports Illustrated I never once
received swimsuit edition in the mail
because that was not something that i
morally believed in I think it was
softcore pornography essentially because
that's what it is this is very very soft
core pornography right it's like
pg-13-rated porn okay that but the idea
that you paint a word on a woman's body
and suddenly the man sees the word and
not the body it's just idiot it's
idiotic this is the height of idiocy but
that's not the extent of it this year
the issue will include more
participation from athletes written
contributions from models yes that's
what we need
written contributions for models I care
deeply what Brooklyn Decker has to say
about the state of Syria I need to I
need to hear from from models who are
most famous for getting naked for the
for the pleasure of men I need to hear
from them about about the patriarchy
more donations and causes and
empowerment one models t-shirt reads own
it last year's issue pretended to change
I guess that one was from last year the
one that said a woman doesn't have to be
modest to be respected again how about a
woman seeks respect rather than seeking
to make money off men pleasuring
themselves to her picture how about that
as any of you how about in order to be
respected I think first you need a
little bit of self-respect is that too
much to ask I think that's not so much
to ask in the first in its 54 year
history the 2018 swimsuit issue will all
show the feature a nude spread shot by
female photographer and an all women
crew Wow
like any dude gives two craps about that
how many guys have actually watched the
credits at the end of a porn movie have
any guy ever watched the credits if they
could be directed by all
that doesn't matter separating the I
will say this men who watch pornography
have a gift for separating the art from
the artist all right they have a unique
capacity to be able to say I don't care
who made this film all I care about is
that there are two women making out on
screen naked it's amazing how that works
and to be sure this year's swimsuit
issue will still have the swimsuits and
sandy beaches its readers have come to
expect the cover was shot in the
Caribbean like approximately 20 of the
ones that preceded it
these are sexy photos des said at the
end of the day we're always going to be
sexy no matter what is happening where
Sports Illustrated swimsuit the idea is
to create something artful to create a
beautiful image that both the subject
and the team is proud of and
collaborates on together and then she
says she sees the connections between
the me2 movement and her own work quote
it's about allowing women to exist in
the world without being harassed or
judged regardless of how they like to
present themselves ok again this is one
of the great lies of the modern feminist
movement is that women love presenting
themselves this way it's empowering for
women to present themselves this way the
number if this were true you know how
many women would be walking around
wearing nothing you know how many women
like how many times have you seen a
woman dressed like that woman
you know just walking around during the
day like they they dress it women dress
on the beach in bikinis but the reality
is that the vast majority of women walk
around the workplace wearing stuff that
is relatively modest why because they
don't want men looking at their cleavage
they want men looking at their faces
it's all it's so backwards and what's
amazing about it and one thing I object
to about it is that the feminist
movement says all this kind of stuff
they say all this kind of stuff and then
they yell at religious people for not
being sufficiently respectful toward
women what I am suggesting is that the
feminist movement is not respectful
enough toward women the feminist
movement has made life worse for women a
third wave feminist movement out the
first wave which had women are equal in
should vote of course that's true women
are equal engine work of course that's
true I'm talking that the second and
third wave feminist movement that said
men and women are exactly the same fruit
sex exactly the same true modesty
exactly the same it's obvious nonsense
and this has real ramifications for real
women okay it's not just about men and
the male gaze it's also about men seeing
women in a certain way so one of the
things the feminist movement has done in
modern times is they've said that
pornography can be a feminist issue or
not because women watch pornography -
first of all the percentage of women who
watch pornography is significantly less
than the percentage is significantly
lower than the percentage of men who
watch pornography this will always be
true invariably and always because men
are V are creatures of visual stimulus
we'll seek it out in terms of sex just
the reality
but the feminist movement has embraced
pornography and said that it's
liberating and empowering it is not
liberating and empowering it gives
terrible ideas to men about what women
want from sex ok this is there's a long
long article over at the New York Times
today it's a piece called what teenagers
are learning from online porn and
essentially what it says is it's not
healthy it's not healthy right basically
there is a huge percentage of young men
who are watching pornography and then
they think this is what women want
because in the pornography met again men
are visual learners and they are then
there they're stimulated by visual
imagery and when you're watching
pornography then you are not actually
going to spend a lot of time thinking
about whether this is true or false or
where there are people behind the camera
or not you're just gonna believe what's
in it in pornography women are always
being they're always happy
they're always feeling pleasure and the
more aggressive the man is in
pornography typically the more the woman
enjoys it and the more creative the man
is the more the man's has weird things
to women the more the woman enjoys it
because that's their job is to act like
they're enjoying it but in real life
woman's gonna enjoy this stuff so this
is convincing women is that they have to
try all of these things that men have
seen in pornography in order to hold
their man because it's created a
competitive market for women in the
dating pool and then they presumably
have to pretend to like it in order for
the man to think that it's cool and then
men think women actually do like it cuz
men are stupid again the feminist
movement should have said here is what
women actually believe about sex here's
what women actually feel about sex women
for women particularly sex and intimacy
are deeply intertwined it's why women
orgasm more often by every study in
married relationships or committed
relationships than they do in the sort
of one-night stands that you hear about
in Rihanna songs right women are much
more in comfortable situations with a
partner who they feel comfortable with
women are much more likely to get sexual
pleasure than in these one-night raunch
fests that you see promoted in in Ke$ha
songs and yes I corrected its case like
Ke$ha nakisha
apparently and so this idea that that's
been pushed forward by women that all of
this is liberating for women it the only
people who are feeling liberated right
now are horny men so well done me too
movement well done feminist movement
just geniuses okay time for some things
I like and then we'll do some things
that I hate so things that I like if
we're talking about things that me too
actually should advocate for
is something that me too should spend
some time on here's a rape survivor
talking about a topic that she thinks is
important for me to to glom on to this
thing's started to get you know a little
more violent I knew that I had no way to
defend myself I couldn't carry my gun
was you know unloaded and locked in my
gun cabinet in Virginia god forbid
someone was to ever try to hurt me again
in that way I had a way to protect
myself
but for me I think the me2 movement and
the movement for women's right to
self-defense I mean they sort of go
handle yeah I'm not advocating that
everyone should carry a gun or that
everyone should concealed carry on
campus really what I'm advocating for is
giving women a choice on how to defend
yourself in the way that you best see
fit
yeah but the women's movement isn't
gonna do that there instead going to say
the best way that women can defend
themselves by posing naked in magazines
and then demanding the men respect them
that that's what the media movement is
all about not how do we protect women
from actual rapist actual predators how
do we stop actual evil people from doing
actual evil things no we have to make it
we have to somehow fight against the
biology of men and pretend that writing
women you know words on women's bodies
is somehow going to make things better
for women just absurd other things that
I like so this is pretty amazing and I
do love it there was a they've decided
that the new Gerber baby is is is
actually a baby with Down syndrome which
is just wonderful and pro-life that's
the subtle pro-life message here it is a
little bit of added on The Today Show
thank you it's always been such a good
baby I've never met anyone to come in
contact with Lucas and not smile safe
for me I thought he was adorable and I
thought well maybe the world my Courtney
submitted this picture of Lucas the
winning photo the first time a baby with
Down syndrome has won what was your
reaction when you read that email we had
just walked in to the
we open open the mail and she started
screaming didn't really sit in oh my
goodness
my challenge don't be the next year baby
okay so that's that's really cool that's
really great it is worthwhile noting
here something mildly controversial but
true true if the Left had its way babies
like Lucas would not exist
okay there's it there's a eugenics
movement that is now happening in
Northern Europe particularly eugenic
abortion in which parents who know their
baby has Down syndrome are aborting
their kids before they are born killing
the babies in the womb the idea that
everyone celebrates babies like Lucas is
just not true there's a whole variety of
people who say the babies like Lucas are
a blot on society and should not live or
that the mother has a has a inherent
right to murder a kid in the womb if the
kid has a severe disability like Down
syndrome you know this should remind us
that there is beauty in the diversity of
human life and there there is beauty in
life itself even if somebody has a
disability like Lucas does so it's an
amazing story okay time for a couple of
things that I hate so thing number one I
have to talk about this is becoming a
major issue now so University of
Minnesota has decided to move me off
campus so the president of the
University of Minnesota has now
responded to accusations that the
university was forcing my February 26
lecture off campus originally the group
applied for a 1500 seat theater the
university said no they applied for an
800-seat theater the university said no
they applied for a 500 seat theater the
university said no and then they moved
the entire venue off campus completely
and what they suggested is that it was
all about security so they said is the
university hosts a wide variety of
events welcoming tens of thousands of
people to campus each and every day we
strive to meet the unique needs for each
and every event and the event scheduled
for later this month is no different
when working to accommodate a venue
request our top priority is and will
always be the safety and security of our
university community and with that in
mind the university works with
organizers to determine a location that
meets everyone's needs to the best of
our ability student leaders with
students for a conservative voice and
collegians for constructive tomorrow
worked with student activities staff and
the university of minnesota pd to
determine the space that would
accommodate the 400 and 500 attendants
the group was planning for and that
would allow a variety and they said
assertions the university is moving an
event space for ideological reasons or
that organizers were not involved in the
discussions are patently false okay
there's only one problem okay when you
use security issues to move me off
campus or bar the public from attending
my speeches your balan to the hecklers
veto yeah you are you are there's a back
door discrimination against conservatism
that is happening here conservatives
don't shut down leftist speeches they
don't go and they don't protest leftist
speeches and they don't threaten
violence so leftist speeches and
therefore if Donaghy C codes comes to
University of Minnesota they give him
the 1500 seat auditorium if I come into
University of Minnesota they won't give
it to me
he's leftist threaten violence or their
worries about an Tifa and therefore I
get relegated off campus so it's
basically them saying for your own good
we're gonna put you in solitary
confinement and we're gonna put you
under mandatory confinement for your own
good
well guess what that's not your job your
job is to ensure safety at a venue where
the public can come here and this is not
the only university to do this not just
University of Minnesota this is now
happened at Northwestern University
University of Connecticut University of
California at Berkeley and UCLA and all
of those they barred the public more
generally from coming to the speech out
of security concerns then do a better
job gang the University of Berkeley Cal
they have a football team if 50,000
people show up to that stadium every
week okay they do the same thing at UCLA
and the University of Minnesota and at
Northwestern they somehow can't figure
out how to do security for a 1500 person
event I somehow have my serious
reservations and doubts about this okay
but again if you use security as an
excuse to shut down only one side of the
aisle and a certain point you have to
ask whether in fact this is viewpoint
discrimination or at least back to our
viewpoint discrimination okay other
things that I hate so president Trump
had announced that he wanted to a
military parade I thought this is a
waste of money if we're going to a
military parade let's do it to honor the
soldiers after we win a war for a 1991
for example or for Memorial Day or for
Veterans Day that'd be a perfect time to
do it but let this couldn't have a
reasoned conversation about this so they
decided to lose their minds so Ironman
Kona used some lefty tweeted quote we
already have 13 people who signed up to
lay down in front of the tanks of Trump
brings out a military parade this is not
a military authority reinstate we would
you join us
hashtag Trump parade okay and then he
tweeted a picture of Tiananmen Square
okay Tiananmen Square was not a military
parade there's a protest going on and
they sent in the military shut down
oh test if leftist want to set and stand
in front of American tanks let's see how
well that goes for them let's see if
that's it that's a winning PR move by
them okay final thing that I hate today
so as I mentioned Shawnee is I think his
name is shawni green so Shawnee green is
is one of the Olympians who is up for
the position of carrying the carrying
the flag Shani Davis I'm sorry Shani
Davis
so Shani Davis is a speed skater and
according to CNN it's Erin Hamlin who's
a world-renowned loser a two-time world
champion four-time Olympian and Shani
Davis these were the two people who are
up for he's a decorated speed skater
five-time Olympics qualifier the flag
bearer is typically chosen in a vote of
eight us winter sport Federation's okay
this year Hamlin and Davis tied at 4-4
so they'd a coin toss and Hamlin was
chosen so what did Davis tweet Davis
tweeted quote I am an American and when
I wasn't they 1000 meter in 2010 I
became the first American to to Pete in
that event Team USA dishonorably tossed
a coin to decide it's 2008 flag bearer
no problem I can wait until 2022 so coin
tosses are now racist which is just
spectacular
apparently they should have chosen him
because he was black he hashtag Black
History Month 2018 I don't understand
what you being black why does that mean
that you get to carry the flag as
opposed to the lady who won the coin
toss our women not victimized an
American citing intersectionality fight
yeah so that's always amusing when when
Democrats decide to fight one another
leftist decide to fight one another of a
coin tosses that are racist legitimately
the definition of a random event is now
considered racist so very very exciting
stuff all right we will be back here
tomorrow with all of the latest updates
on all of the latest news i'm ben
shapiro this is the bench bureau show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Plummer executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is austin stevens
edited by alex and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Jesuit Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for publishing 2018